[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هنا في حاره العقر قرر الاهالي اعاده
الحياه الى منازلهم القديمه عبر تحويلها
الى نزلا تراثيه استقبال السياح سواء من
داخل السلطنه او خارجي
[موسيقى]
تمتاز ولايه نزوى بوفره نزول التراثيه
وقيام سكانها بترميم البيوت القديمه
للاستفاده منها في تنشيط القطاع السياحي
الذي يعتبره الكثيرون واعدا في السلطنه
خلال السنوات القليله المقبله
[موسيقى]
بعد عشر سنوات من الاخر ولكن ما شاء الله
كان اسرع بكثير مما كنا ننظم هذا كان
بالنسبه لنا ايضاعم معنوي وحافظ قوي على
انه يعجل عمليات الترميم والاصلاح في
الحاره ومثل ما تشاهدون الان عمليات
التربيه المستمره وكثيره وباذن الله تعالى
في مشاريع كثيره قادمه للموقع هذا
[موسيقى]
حاره العقر التاريخيه في نزوى تضم 16 برج
القديمه بالاضافه الى اربع بوابات وصور
عتيق يصل طوله الى كيلو مترين في هذه
الحاره القديمه تم تحويل 30 بيتا تراثيا
الى نزل فندقي وهناك 40 بيتا تم ترميمها
حتى الان
[موسيقى]
لما بدانا بهذه الخط والجاريه ونعنيها
بكلمه الجريئه لان مكلف اعاده احياء هذه
الحوائر فكانت يعني ردت فعل ايجابيه جدا
بدات من اعاده يعني عوده السكان الاصليين
اللي كانوا يسكنوا هذه الحاره اعاده
الاقامه فيها وهذا ايضا قال من الاجانب
ايضا مصدر الهام لهم وتجربه فريده عندما
يزوره سلطنه عمان وبالذات نزوى فكانت افضل
تجربه انهم يقيموا في حاره اثريه قديمه
[موسيقى]
الكثير من هذه المنازل القديمه سكنها
شخصيات مهمه في تاريخ سلطنه عمان من علماء
دين ورجالات السياسه ووجها اي مجتمع ما
اعطى هذه الحاره قيمه تاريخيه لا تزال
باقيه
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه نزوى العربيه